this is a production of Cornell
University
solution for the invitation is my great
pleasure to uh to present our address
and work on watermelon genomics actually
I
recently asked me to give a talk I
thought I just give a talk at the planet
biology did I checked my slides it's
three years ago
so you decided if I can provide any
updates after three years so here I am I
will mostly the work during the past
three years on watermelon genomics
so here is the outline of my talk today
but I will provide background of
watermelon and the the genus the tallest
genus then I will present the our
last five years effort on reference
genome sequencing of watermelon now talk
about watermelon origin complicating and
Improvement and the last I will talk
about the the pendulum of watermelon
so as you know watermelon is a worldwide
growing crop is a very popular fruit
crop the annual production is about 100
tons so that's rank this third among the
fruit carbs is if you can't tomato as a
fruit crop not a vegetable crop so it's
only after tomato and bananas
so watermelon is also also a nutritious
crop it contains high levels of lycopene
it's higher than any other fresh fruit
and vegetable even higher than tomato
and acetylene this is the compound that
originally different from watermelon
that's why it's called Citroen because
the Latin name of acetylus so this is
amino acid that beneficial for health
and exercise exercise performance
and also because of the compound
some media claims watermelon is a
natural Viagra but little we found out
that if you want to have the Viagra
effect you have to get maybe tons of
watermelon once that's not possible
Right but anyway it does provide health
and and the health benefits for humans
so watermelon belongs to the Cucumbers
family so this family contains about 95
General and about 1 000 species so
including some well-known fruit crops
fruit and vegetable crops like cucumber
melon squash zucchini Burger all kinds
of gods right
the one man belongs to the ceteros genus
so this journals contains seven extended
species
the carted of watermelon belongs to the
subspecies vulgaris of this lanata
species so the another species also also
contains another subspecies called
codophanus this is a wild form
watermelon so I will spend quite a lot
of today's talk on this species
and we also have the
uh the six wire species and among them
three of them nucleus promos amaras and
consensus had already been used widely
used in watermelon breeding program to
improve the disease resistance and
abiotic stress tolerance
the Cardiff watermelon has a very narrow
genetic diversity because of the
bottleneck automation the bottleneck and
is susceptible to all kinds of diseases
and pest infections
so we need no more modern genome tools
to facilitate the watermelon research
and breeding
so next I will talk about our effort in
reference genome sequencing I think
everyone knows the graphically genome
provider foundation for breeding from
the foundational tools for breeding and
research
we start we initiated the watermelon you
know graphite genomes project in
actually in 2008
led by a group uh of the international
science science the mainly by Young
enemy
so at that time they used the short read
technology Illumina technology to
assembled uh high quality reference
Genome of watermelon Captiva 17.3 so
1713 and 9713 is the Cardinal name it's
an East Asia type
it's a highly inputed line
and we published this in 2013. done with
the technology advancement we uh we
generate an improved version of 9713
genome using the laundries and also the
banana maps and high c maps we we this
this version of The genome was much hard
was much improved than the previous
version
so meantime in collaboration with Armon
Levy we generate a high quality genome
for challenging gray this is a principle
American waterline watermelon Carnival
you can see the difference between 9713
and Charles and gray
so during the past couple of years we
spend a lot of effort on generating
reference genome for wild watermelons so
this is the one in collaboration with
Susan Renault we we produce a high
quality Genome of the code of finals The
Wider form of watermelon and which could
be the direct protection of cardio
watermelon I will talk about this later
and we also generate the reference
genome for these three wire species that
are used in the breeding program because
the promos amaras and collisions
so all this all this this Regional has
not been published but is available in
the database we developed
so with this reference genome the uh
they not only provide a valuable
resource for fundamental research and
breeding but I also gave us the
opportunity to understand or study the
the evolution of watermelon genomes so
by comparative genomic analysis we can
even for the philosophy of this
watermelon species and also the
Divergence time of this species
and through the comparative genomic
analysis we can also identify large
genome rear Arrangements between the
typical genomes of the species here is
it shows that there's a into chromosome
rear Arrangement between chromosome 1
and common four in color senses compared
to other three species
okay with this reference genome it gives
us opportunity to understand watermelon
orangey
so how many of you know that which
continent that a watermelon was
originated
okay right A lot of people studies from
Asia
because you know the cucumber and the
melon the origin from Asia so people
also think oh what men are probably also
originally from Asia but not it's
originated from Africa and distributed
to the world
so during dramatication and operating
wild watermelon you can see here the
wild watermelon it's more
hair color and a heart and a beetle then
become the uh
crisp large crisp sweet and a red flesh
and the seed and the paintings of
watermelon had been found in Egyptian
Pharaoh's tomes so this home was built
like about 4 000 years ago so this
indicates that a watermelon has been
dominated for at least four thousand
years
for several critical questions related
to watermelon origin and abominification
Studio remain unanswered
this the first one is what is a direct
projector of cultural watermelon so this
is a very important question
and the second one is kind of related to
the first one so where in Africa was a
watermelon first automatically which
part you know if you if you can identify
the direct progenitor then you can also
also answer the second question so the
first two attack routine can be answered
if you can identify the drug progenitor
and also what are the genetic bases for
watermelon to medication so during the
past several years we spend a lot of
effort using the population genomics
approach try to address these questions
as I mentioned identifying the uh the
crop wire per generator is very
important they can help you to
understand domestication and also can
help you have your breathing
but identify why the progenitor is quite
difficult
the main reason is that the white
version may be distinct is not existed
anymore and also hybridization with
cardiograph species and in
distinguishable from the federal forms
so uh there are four hypotheses of
cardboard watermelon origin the fourth
one this is actually what the dominant
one since from 1930 to 2013.
it's from this the southern Africa City
melon
it's uh you see the amaras it's this one
the pink one from Southern Africa
and a little we found out this is this
is a mistake then the second hypothesis
is the northern African consensus this
area
this other one is the western African
equation with Microsoft promos this one
and then the fourth one is the Northeast
Eastern Africa the code finals from the
Sudan region
so as I just show you that based on the
genome sequencing a reference genome
analysis we found this quarterfinals the
wide form codifinals are closely related
to the uh cultural watermelon this gives
an indication that this one could be the
direct project of watermelon
then we at meantime we did the genomic
resequencing to sequence the larger
populations so in this study we report a
total of more than 400 accessions that
have been deep sequenced
and in another study we we checked we
investigate the uh the John plasma
collection in the uh
USDA National plant genome gen plant
system that includes about 1300
accessions but this one we use the
genotyping by sequencing
technology to for genotyping
and using the uh the gene the snip
derived from DBS data for the uh for the
jump lamp collection and also for the
derived from genome real sequencing for
the more than 400 accessions weighing
for the phylogenic relationship between
okay
so we uh we in for the phylogenic
relationship among all these accessions
one interesting finding is that all the
uh This Server very few could find the
accession that we can we can have at
that time so four of them
that's all for that we have in the John
Prime system and this too
we included in this study like actually
let's do another for our lab so in total
we have four accessions in the general
system and also the class that are the
base of category
cardio watermelon clay
and it says give you hand that this uh
this code finals could be the direct
progenitor right because they are all of
them are clouds related to the kind of
species and also we did uh in in that
study we did the gene flow analysis
we found this noting flow between the
amaras so this one the Citron melon
there are Mars to the Cardinal species
so this reject this first hypothesis and
also based on phylogenic tree you can
see a Marathi is quite distant from the
cardiovas species so later we found out
that this was a taxonomy error by a
student in
in some lab I mean in Germany in some
lab the the mistakenly uh labeled uh
calculated species as a mothers
so when they do some other analysis like
phenotype morphology and using some SSR
markers they found that one was very
close to the kind of species so they
claim that this America was direct per
janitor and that's starting from 1930
then in 2013 when we published the first
reference genome people we found out
this is the arrow there's no way that
amaras is the direct projector and also
the the I mean from this philajini
announcer we can easily reject consensus
because the color sensity is even
further away
than Mrs to compared to the uh Wireless
Cardiff species
so now uh we uh we left with uh igushi
melon and the code of Finance melon
we are trying to provide more evidence
okay so we are trying to provide more
evidence to support that code of America
was a direct projector
the fortunately are Susan Renault got a
bag of seeds that are collect from Sudan
it's not easy to collect stuff from
Sudan because of war and and traveling
condition is very bad but we we
fortunately got a one bag of seeds and
they send me a back seat and also soon
another bag to uh the same about the
same seat to Cecilia at the University
of Georgia
to make inbred to cross the self safe
clothes the seed to Pure the the
material
so with that we got 15 seats from
Cecilia and we grow them at Pita
Greenhouse and we did a genome
resequencing for all these 15 accessions
and you can see
we did the photogenic analysis and all
15 was was a clustered in a separate
clade but it is closely more the most
closely related to the domestic
watermelon this provides another
evidence to support that
uh called the finals is a duration
but and also with detaching flow between
quarterfinals to the cardiovas water
metal
and another hypothesis is that this coat
of a melon they are in Wild form
but they could be pharaoh
the domesticated before but escaped from
the medication become wild
and if that's the case they should have
the similar nuclear diversity with the
card with the watermelon
we perform the uh the pi the nuclear
diversity analysis found out that the
the coat of our model uh
codified code founder has much higher
nuclear diversity than cut watermelon so
this indicates that qualified metal is
not like a ferroform it is a direct
progenitor of categor watermelon so then
we answered the first question right
then we know that the codified metal was
from Sudan the North Eastern area of
Africa then we can conclude that a
watermelon could be first automated in
Northeast Africa
okay with the uh the direct projector
then we can we can also
the question we can we can investigate
the genetic basis or genomic basis of
watermelon domestication and Improvement
so
give you a little bit of background I
think most of you already know that
corrupt me during corporate
communication there's a lot of
morphological changes or trade changes
so this table is the main trade changes
the first one the the edible part like
fruit grain become larger like in tomato
the fruit become one more almost 100
times larger than their direct
progeninal
and the fruit has a high ability like
the wild watermelon like cucumber that
bitter right and even wild tomato
they have some bad taste so you don't
want to eat them so now with the modern
and also sweet
right it's more edible and then they
have high levels of student generation
and the growth habit but one good trade
the loss is the the tolerance to bad
antibiotic stresses kind of like showing
in this uh in that picture so this is a
wild tomato grown in these hot
conditions there's no way that they cut
a tomato can survive or grow well in
this kind of conditions and this wild
tomatoes they can they can get fruit has
no problem
so that's why the current breeding
program you want to use Wild
uh
species to increase the the tolerance
so I've also gave you some several
examples on how much
the communication changed the phenotype
so do you guys know what is this crop
the wild crop
anyone know that what is this
okay it's a carrot you can see the
difference
after medication
so this one
no it's eggplants
the wild eggplants then this is the
early Dometic case of eggplants so you
can see that's why they call eggplants
it's like egg
right
so this is a more than eggplants
medication and the modern breeding
and there's this one this one should be
easy to guess right banana
[Laughter]
you can see that during the
domestication history the changes of
corn right this this is why the one then
this is uh this is a a coin found in
like seven thousand years ago
then compared to to more than one
so we are lucky with that we have all
kinds of those fruit and crops to eat
but like seven thousand years ago you
have to eat this kind of stuff
foreign
can be uh can be classified in two
stages the fourth one is dominication
and this is not a real representation of
the landeries it's a the painting from
uh 17th century
that means people in 17 17th century
could lead one melon like this
than uh to after Improvement to Modern
sweet dessert watermelon you can see all
kinds of this trays will change like
sugar content flesh color bitterness
texture Aroma size everything
so then we are we have this population
genomic sequencing data we have the
reference genome then we can use this
data to understand the genomic basis of
watermelon duplication and breathing so
in this paper
we are in our 2019 paper we at that time
we don't know which one is the direct
progenitor of the cut watermelon
and also we don't have much accession of
the quarter finals to work with so in
that paper we just use this Microsoft
promos
as a representative
of the progenitor of Donatos because its
fruit was not Dominican so this this
water species has some kind of
dominication for seed consumption
but
it's not a real direct progesterone so
the there could be some information
missing if you use this as a as a
representative of direct projector
but at that time we have no choice but
you still give you some interest in
findings but you will miss or maybe give
you some wrong conclusions right using
this so as I mentioned we got 15 uh
accessions
from Cecilia we grow them in bti and
actually my my student and poster tasted
all 15 of them I also tested some of
them and they are they taste like
watermelon
none of them are better
and then not sweet so you can see the uh
the bricks but content is very very the
sugarcane is very very low the break is
0.2 to 3.2 the modern cardioid is like
10 or 11. is much lower much higher than
the quarter-finals
and we also saw some pink
colored pink flat watermelon in color
Finance so
and this provides us the this this uh
accessions and the genomic sequences
provide us to opportunity to revisit
watermelon communication
so we compelled the
the Cordova melon with the controller
fundamental with boundaries the lunaries
with modern cardiova to identify
domestication sweeps and the Improvement
sweeps and we identified about 20
million breast payouts of the genome
regions and under selection
about 400 and 700 genes that are in this
selective region all this genes are
under selection
so as you know in watermelon fruit
smoothness
is the most interesting
Target or trace for domestication and
even now for breeding people still talk
a lot a lot about the the sweetness
and this slide shows the uh the sugar
content
in different species
and in Learners and and modern Carnival
the sugarcane is much much higher than
the uh
the quarterfinals and other wild forms
so we identified a genome region
that under selection that overlap with
the northern sugar qtls like this uh
uh this cuties the cutest in blue
what's was what under selection during
both the multiplication and Improvement
and this qtl was that under selection
during the medication but not in
Improvement this one
was in uh in Improvement but not in
termification
so through the business
so we found out that uh all could Define
us are not beaten
and also the the one major Gene
regulating through the business in
watermelon that's clbt Gene you can see
the the nucleotide diversity uh around
this Gene has no difference between the
quarterfinals
and cartilage watermelon
but the nuclear diversity was was much
higher in the Microsoft performance so
is that a means this Gene was not
selected during Dome education this kind
of kind of like uh uh
against previous studies or previous
Source because people always thought in
cucumbers business is a big is a major
selection automatic agent trade but our
study says it's not in at least in
watermelon
it's not automatician trade because they
already being fixed in the wild
progenitor
and how they become fixed in this wider
progenitor that's an interesting
question and so what we don't know we
don't know why this trade was fixed in
the wild form
Amazon flesh color we found out that uh
the
the wide project already have the
red-fledged uh flat color this is also
different from previous studies because
people thought about the flat color was
introduced during the multiplication
because all this uh
all the other wired forms except the
codifinals they they don't have red
flash it's about Flash
so previous started using these
materials they saw that communication
the red color was was happened in during
domesticating or early early stage of
domication but actually we found out
it's not the case the the flat red flag
color already in the wild progenitor of
cardio watermelon
and this one gene the the lcyp lcby like
beans data cyclists this is a major
thing controlling watermelon fruit flesh
color and you can see the diversity of
this surrounding this thing was
decreased
when you're when you compare the
quarter-fi Mellow the this brown one is
codified mellow and then laundry is it's
kind of one and also with the modern
cutting ones so this indicates that this
Gene was under selection
and also the uh the red color was a
selection trade Dominican trade
so the combine all this evidence we
think that a watermelon geodometrication
could have started with red Flash
foreign right but this is not sweet and
also this variation of the blacks or
sugar solid solid solid syllable solid
content of the uh in the wild progenitor
so they may start with the the red one
because also the red one has higher
breaks values they must start this for
domitication
okay meantime uh as I mentioned before
the wild watermelons has been used
in modern breeding program to increase
the abiotic antibiotic stress tolerance
so using this genome sequencing data we
are trying to identify genome regions
the footprint of integration
in the modern watermelon genome so we
did find a region on corruption six
from the uh
uh amaras the silhou melon and this
region contains genes related to a
pottery Mutual resistance or tolerance
to hypoxia or low phosphate conditions
this is as expected because the reason
we bring this in is to increase its
tolerance and we also identify a region
on chromosome 4 that were introgressed
from cholesterols and this one
was a contains the qtl that are related
to form resistance
okay so next I will talk about the uh
the pan genomes of Cardigan and white in
the watermelons
so you can see from this picture there's
a white uh phenotypical variation of
even in within but kind of the
watermelon so this indicates that
one genome couldn't provide a
compressible reference
uh to evaluate the genetic diversity of
watermelon so that's why we need a pan
genome
so as I mentioned before we have
reference genome for for NASA Monastery
Charles and gray called finals and these
three wide species and we also did
reported the genome resequencing that
414 accessions
in 2019 and during the past several
years a couple of years we generate
quite a lot of new genome resequencing
mainly on the wide species
and you can see here the the
the denominator segments about the main
and cardinal so we we are focusing on uh
genome generating genomics and wild
species so here is the final
resequencing data the summary of final
basic in the data we have
more than 400 we have
close to 550 organizations that have
been deep sequenced in watermelon
and this the reference genome and the
genome recent data provide a solid
foundation for our pendulum work
so we use the map to par approach to
construct the watermelon pangino
and the Nova assembly for each exercise
we do know assembly we generate
connected map to reference then we
identify normal sequences that are not
in the reference genome and normal genes
and because the high height Divergence
between these different species so we
construct reports contract pendulum for
each species because we have reference
genome for each species
okay
we have identified about
2288 novel genes
next to the promos were identify much
less about 600 genes in a 2010 Nova
genes in amaras and 2500 genes in
cholecisors and the the
the
genes we check the presence and absence
variation of each gene in the population
and we found out that the code genes in
in different
species are quite High
that means the genes present in all
accessions in that species
because those promos 97 this is why it's
very high and um 90 and the conditions
is 88 percent
so after we construct this four species
specific pan genomes we integrate them
into a simple functional water
watermelon superpang genome so what we
do we we lift our genes among the first
species to try to identify the
orthological relationships between each
panel or among those pan genomes
we also use synthetic team blocks to
help to identify or to
establish orthological relationships so
in the end we identified about 38 000
osologic Gene groups
in the pan genome
and most of them they have the
synthetical orthological relationships
and uh some of them they are specific to
one the one one one species
so the pan genome has much less core
content called Gene content it's six
four percent
so this indicates the diverse genetic
makeup among the four species this is
understandable because in the species
variation is much bigger than within
species variations
and we also found that during
automatication this is the code of a
melon this is a landeries and a
cardiovas we found there's a trend
of Gene loss during automatication this
also founded in tomato the the pendulum
we report in in 2019
so we checked the 18 we analyzed editing
presence absent variation pattern and
identified genes has a highly
differentiate
frequency highly different frequency
among different populations
and we did not find much genes that are
showing highly different
uh
uh earlier or team president variation
frequency
during domestication and during
Improvement
so this is also understandable because
the history is very short like
communication is like several thousand
years and the Improvement just several
hundred years compared to this uh this
species Divergence that's
a million years ago several million
years ago
but we uh we
analyze this data set the the present
evidence variation we did find quite a
lot of interesting stuff so here we I
will give you a
couple of examples the first one is the
disease resistant Gene we find quite a
lot of genes this disease resists in the
genes
that are missing
in in cardiova and also in their direct
progenita or very low frequency so this
one means that this Gene presented in
all accessions we invested in consented
species
so this uh like this 93
0.937 that means 93 percent of our
accessions in that species contains this
Gene so zero means that no oxidation the
gene is absent in all accessions you can
see
we have a huge amount of accessions in
Carter 243
88 Inland race and all of them does not
contain these genes
and this provides a valuable resource
for Target breeding for for disease
resistance right we know that these are
known Target uh disease resistant genes
and they are missing in
modern cardiova and then we can
introduce them to the modern cardio to
improve the disease resistance
so the other one is a church study so
this Gene is a tonoplast sugar
transporter
and based on our analysis we found they
are this Gene is a tournament
duplication in Cardiff species at least
the united
we checked this tandem duplication in
different watermelon populations
and they found out that in water species
almost all of them are single copy it's
not a kind of duplication and except one
of them
all this population only one of their
accessions have the tandem duplication
but you can see in land race in learners
the tandemic duplication
has become much more common and in in
cultiva is almost fake fixed only very
few has single copies
and we identified one Collision one
called final accession has two copies
and it turns out that this this
accession has the highest sugar content
among all these 15. call the final
successions and we also checked the uh
the in cultiva and the learnerase
we checked the sugar contents in
accessions with tandem multiplication
and other accessions contain contain one
single copy we found out that the
tournament duplication has much higher
sugar content than this the accessions
with one single copy
and we checked this Gene the nuclear
diversity of the city and find out that
this
this the nuclear diversity of the team
has automatically reduced during
dometication
that means this Gene is automatician
Target
okay oh uh depending on reconstructed
was was based on map to power approach
and the next couple of slides I will
briefly mentioned our ongoing work using
the graph pan genome so the ground pan
genome can represent they can uh put the
instructions deletions into one graph
the multiple approach is a linear
representation of the genome so this is
a graph pendulum a graph representation
of multiple genomes
and it has a lot of advantages
and like single coordinate system you
know can improve grid mapping and
environment detection
but it requires much more reference to
create genomes
so this like a couple years ago this is
not realistic
because of the technical limitation but
now it's become feasible
like the Hi-Fi due to the high five
technology it can generate generate the
red length of 15 KB that's 15 times of
single sequencing about 150 times of
Illumina sequencing
and the base accuracy is 99.5 is is
equivalent to Illumina sequencing
so this gives us a lot of opportunity to
build to generate much more reference
genomes so in collaboration with Dr
yongxi we generate we already generate
more than 130 reference genomes for
watermelon
it's all reference level using Hi-Fi so
this is the number shows
the uh the number of accessions that are
used for graphing genome sequencing in
each species so we only have one
[Music]
system we only have this accession
available
so that's why we only have one or two
reference genome for this species
and this slide shows this part this
table shows that the number of
configures that are assembled in each
chromosome
and you can see in most chromosomes
those in green
the entire chromosome was assembled in
one country
the the the the the biggest one could be
four
all right so that's still oh this one
this one six but in most chromosomes was
somebody one two configures thanks to
the hal-fi technology
and uh
and my student resident identified the
structural variations of using this
reference genome the whole genome
alignments
using the 97 minus 3 genome as a
reference we identified quite a few
insertions and deletions and it
surprisingly that we got a huge amount
of deletions and transactions in wider
species almost one sort of the genome
design has research and deletions so we
are in the process of in group of
constructing constructing a graph based
pan genome by integrating this reference
genome and the structure variations into
one single graph and this one single
graph can be used to genotype the uh the
grease sequencing data we generate like
this 500
547 and also we are in the process of
generating the genomic resequencing
of a core collection we have developed
and I'm pretty sure that this
comprehensible data will give you a
much more broad or in-depth
knowledge of watermelon communication
and the Improvement related to this
traits
so with that I would like to thank
people in my lab the wonderful graduate
students and apostas and also my
collaborators and the funding from UCA
project in the National Science
Foundation thanks for your attention I
would like to take any questions
yes
do you think the reduction of bitterness
and the progenitor and the increase in
the color red is is due to selection
from mammals that might have distributed
the seeds
so you mean the uh the the non-putinous
right the reduction of bitterness any
increase of color
you could be caused by the uh animal
distribution of the seeds
yeah that's it's possible but I'm
thinking why not have any other wild
species
only in this what a species
they grow up together
they overlap their distributions uh like
color senses overlap with with uh with
uh with the code of finals but it could
be a reason but we don't have much
evidence it's possible yeah
I uh very impressive thought
um
yeah so I was wondering how so if the
modern watermelons has been domesticated
in Africa before they just distributed
into Asia or Europe or uh America or
just they just uh domesticated in
Asia or Europe or America
okay yeah I use this first question
another question is like more General so
I was wondering
um how what kind of like you know
principle or general principle to decide
or to determine the origin of the modern
uh Cordova of the watermelon so because
um based on the the close you know is it
that's based on the the wild watermelon
with the closest genome
with the the modern watermelon or just
some other principle okay yeah so the
fourth question is uh where does the
watermelon was Atomic kid fourth thing
in Africa the anticipated to the world
then just while the District of the
world then Dominican local in like in
Asia locally yeah no I think the uh the
the author is that the the fourth
stomacher in Africa
then uh the only dominant case will
bring to the world
than
each continent like Asia America they
have their own breeding program to
improve watermelon
right there's no way that the the wire
species bring the white species to the
world than communication
yeah this one this should be clear yeah
yeah so the second question can you
repeat your question again yeah
basically so just general questions like
what general principle to determine
determine the orange origin of one of
the cardboard or your origin of
watermelon yeah I mean I mean to
determine the crop origin is is quite
difficult as I mentioned
mainly people using the existing wild
species to to analyze their
morphological difference their
uh genetic difference if they find a
virus species that are closely most
closely related to the cardiovas species
and
one possibility is that this this
velocity could be feral
that it came from communication become
wild and you then you you have to rule
out this possibility
there are some people based on this
analysis they claim the
that this one could be I mean it's not
100 could be the direct projector of
cardiovas species because
why you can't 100 sure because
there could be another species wide
species that are not existed anymore
then you can
you can't identify them but if you find
lucky if you find a
wider form you got a high highly closed
related to the Cardinal species
then
using them even it's not 100 as a wide
progenitor using this as a
representative of wire projector for
analysis it can still give you a lot of
information on the medication
yes
it was a great talk so my question is
kind of about generally speaking not
just about watermelon um about plant
breeding uh and selecting the right
traits for domestication so is there a
sort of trade-off between uh pest
resistance and drought resistance and
some of the the things you want to breed
back into watermelon and all the other
agriculturally uh
you know sweetness the the other things
we really like about the crop is there
is there a general uh trade-off there
and that's an issue for all crop
development yeah very good question so
so actually the from genetic point of
view there could be a linkage so there
could be a title link of two trades
right I have a fruit size right but the
third link there was a a successful
traits right I wanted to increase fruit
size
at the meantime you bring the acceptable
Allure to the modern cardiovan so that
that that's uh that's quite a lot so we
there are some studies in tomato they
find quite a lot of dinky uh between the
two feet so another one is that for some
trades
people don't like right but they can't
resistant to to pathogens or or insects
like a beetle yeah yeah bitterness right
and then you you fruit it better than
animal or pets didn't want to eat but
people also don't want it they get rid
of the bitterness then they decrease the
resistance to pests okay okay yeah thank
you very much actually this is a really
great seminar and um let's go
thank you thank you
[Music]
um
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell.edu